[Musica]
gelateria strana
gelati
no questo è troppo buono non lo voglio
per forza sì sì sì sì allora prendo il
11 il 12
se non c'hanno il 12 prendo il 9 poi
voglio il 14 il centro 17 519 signora
dei gelati visivamente gelati velo da il
119 buongiorno signor giro taglio allora
duca vorrei il numero 157 147 11 e 14
dhabi dove tu ce l'avevi il camioncino
dei gelati ma sempre
[Musica]
devo andare a salvarlo
la mamma
[Musica]
gelateria strana se nessuno ei
se qualcuno nessuno
che cosa è successo
ho rotto solo taglio cattivo ice cream
sia iscritto ho visto primati ha
congelato ha congelato ma vuol dire che
ti vuole trasformare in un gelato o no
io lo voglio montoro il gelato non
diventare come faccia a liberarti devi
trovare tutti gli effetti non è qui
dentro che sono sparsi in giro e poi
riuscirò a liberarsi devi trovare la
chiave per aprirmi da cui vi scongiuro
armi ma non posso offrirti d'acqua
direttamente sorvolo già aiuto
ok allora tu aspetta qua di vieste
impaziente però ok
pensavo di andare in spiaggia come in
spiaggia ma si sono succedute pure
faccia dello stub armi da qui hai
ragione voi che chiudo la porta solo
porta ferro lascia la porta aperta così
è troppo di caldo magari farò del mio
meglio trovano sugli oggetti per i
cinesi e porta un piatto di minestra
così di gas caldo
ok vado subito importante e cercherò di
trovare tutto
ok ragazzi
il primo oggetto da trovare una cassetta
degli attrezzi berlino devi aiutarmi con
il tuo fiuto a trovare questo oggetto
con il tuo fiuto infallibile
cerchiamo la cassetta degli attrezzi
assieme ma non dobbiamo essere presi da
ice cream prot
altrimenti game over se questo video
raggiunge i 30 mila mi piace ci sarà
anche ice scream 2 nella realtà e ora
siete pronti andiamo vetrino sta
fiutando qualcosa seguiamolo come questa
nella cassetta degli attrezzi
aiutami a cercarla usera mi sta portando
da qualche parte vediamo perché si sono
dei pop corn qua ma chi è buttato di pop
corn e scommetto che è stato vitale
berlino non mangiare adesso berlino
divinità come trovare la cassetta degli
attrezzi ti prego dobbiamo svegliarci o
no
eccolo ma sta privando borsa team e sta
dietro questa pioggia
ma dietro
intanto
allora perché mi sta guardando tutti
forse meglio disposto da qui ma aspetta
momento che cos'è questo sì l'ho trovata
ok sono riuscita a seminar lo devo
riuscire a entrare dentro casa berlino
sta attento però dopo avvicini
ap volo cassetta degli attrezzi apriamo
il progetto andiamo
se siamo riusciti a seminare andiamo ora
proviamo ad aprirlo vediamo cosa c'è
dentro non sia l'evoluzione bloccato
devo trovare un altro oggetto per aprire
la cassetta degli attrezzi l'altro
oggetto è il cacciavite
[Musica]
ok c'è mancato poco
la cassetta degli attrezzi non si apre
dobbiamo trovare il cacciavite per
aprirla so cosa ci sarà ha detto
dobbiamo sbrigarci per salvare evitare
prima che venga trasformato in un bagno
ma alle noccioline o altri stage
adesso
mi sembra che ci siano
[Musica]
siamo stati molto fortunati a trovare la
cassetta degli attrezzi ma il cacciavite
più piccolo
non so se riusciremo a trovarlo qualcosa
mi dice che potrebbe essere dentro la
gelateria di ice cream
proviamo a dare un'occhiata sperando che
lui non sia dentro
non va
non mi sembra di vedere niente dentro
niente un sacco di paura che spunti
fuori all'improvviso magari magari qua
nella cabina guidatore lo so proviamo ad
aprile
se venir volante non mi sembra di vedere
niente
eccolo ragazze il cacciavite
non ci credo sono riuscito a trovarlo ok
abbiamo adesso torniamo dentro
mi sembrava strano che non si fosse
fatto vedere tutto questo tempo fate
fare nascosto stata ti ho rubato il
cacciavite dove mi chiedo aiuto lo
capiamo
non penso che riesca ad aprire forte no
maledizione che aprire forte stiamo
studiando prima che è finito cosa devo
fare adesso forse le può aprire la
cassetta evitarlo che cosa offrirà
questa chiave si nota il numero 5
cosa vorrei dire quindi forse
questo è l'ultimo oggetto allora sei
l'ultimo oggetto aprirà la coppia
dobbiamo subito andare ad aprirlo allora
ecco lì che mi sta guardando
per fortuna non ha fatto niente a
berlino per fortuna non sa chi è stato
berlino ma che fa merlino dove sta
andando
non si deve avvicinare lui sta
controllando la sua gelateria oppure me
sta aspettando no no come faccio adesso
uscire visto proprio aspettando lì sarà
impossibile entrare dentro il camper non
fa niente
dobbiamo provarci lo stesso per evitare
che è vitale si trasformi in un cornetto
alla crema
scherzavo
oggi
via libera
ma caffè
ben 1
marino entrare
aiuto bravo berlino bravo berlino di
stravino centro club e berlino no non
può salire quadri distrarlo ok ho chiuso
la porta così rod non può salire
forse lo spero dove vedo più marino ea
porto ferro
pollo paura che spunti fuori
all'improvviso vi devo nascondere sui 20
chiesero anche me
eccolo
che paura o no vai via
ok apriamo vitale speriamo che non si
sia trasformato in un gelato ai un
supporto nativo per fortuna non ti sei
trasformato in un gelato ho trovato la
chiave spero che sia quella giusta
dentro questa chiave va qua qua proviamo
funziona andiamo non fa niente
ascoltami decisamente contento perché
che è successo perché iscrivere che
guarda qualche parte del prof
capiamo subito andiamo andiamo prima che
arrivi qua si trova qua dentro ci
prenderà entrambi sia più andiamo
sbrigati è entrato nella sua gelateria
forse sta andando birra feriale quindi
vuol dire che abbiamo vinto la challenge
ci sono riuscito a prendere le surgelate
ma questa volta sono già occupata ma
lasciate un bel mi piace se volete una
seconda parte e riguardate pure il video
tutte le volte che volete
io però purtroppo non sono riuscito a
prendere le sue lario ma sono contento
di vedere berlinetta mi raccomando verso
chi un bel mi piace ora vi lasciamo con
quattro castellini su cui cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri vi dia cliccare su
quella che preferite